what happened in Afghanistan and other
signaling from America under Biden made
America weaker in the eyes of other
people why do you think there's a crisis
with China now why do you think there's
a crisis with Ukraine these are not
accidents people look at what's
happening here and they go the countries
weak the country's distracted the
country's divided it's time for us to
act but actually it happens but actually
it's not that's the thing is that I I
would have
if you had said to me five years ago
before Trump and before covid do you
think this country will be where we are
right now after those two disasters I
would have said no we're going to be up
shit's creek and actually life goes on
amazingly well the economy is doing it's
like what is unemployment three percent
or something I thought that would take
us down I thought Trump would take us
down I I never thought he would do the
things that other people said I didn't
think he was going to get into a war
everybody was saying that on the left
he's going to get us into war he's going
to crash the market I said no what he's
going to do is try to stay jakku that's
the thing he did do okay but he didn't
do all that life went on where I
feel like America is amazingly resilient
and stable I agree with you
I mean amazingly I I mean I agree
broadly in the sense that you know
there's this kind of catastrophizing
about America since you know I started
paying attention to politics it's every
year and every party does it but the
thing that you have to correct if you're
Democrats is in that same recent poll is
asked if the economy was good or
excellent the numbers were on 17 to 18
percent so it's prices of the pump it's
inflation it's things like that that is
lowered but it has not cleared the decks
in people's minds they still believe
it's a big disaster look Joe Biden
inherited a terrible situation on the
economy but uh I think you misunderstand
me perhaps well I'm not saying America
isn't resilient I'm just saying I think
it's important that America continues to
be a force in the world and it hasn't
been in the way that it ought to be in
my opinion do you you have the
perspective I think that people from New
York